la situación humanitaria se deteriora en
la República democrática del congob este
viernes la agencia de la ONU para los
refugiados expresó su preocupación por
el impacto del conflicto que llevó a
desplazamientos masivos de la población
solo en febrero cerca de 300.000
personas huyeron de los territorios de
uruchuru y massie
los equipos del acnur han informado de
los testimonios más espeluznantes de las
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos
especialmente en los territorios de Ruth
y massie incluidos asesinatos
arbitrarios secuestros extorsiones y
violaciones la semana pasada la Unión
Europea anunció la creación de un puente
aéreo humanitario hacia el este del país
para ayudar a las poblaciones afectadas
este viernes llegó el primer avión
compuesto principalmente De productos
médicos
por el momento el deseo de nuestra
población es por supuesto recibir ayuda
humanitaria
pero su deseo es volver lo antes posible
a sus lugares de origen para alimentarse
cuidarse y alojarse
la República democrática del Congo vive
desde 2021 enfrentamientos entre el
ejército y el grupo Rebelde m23 a
mayoría tutsi el nuevo alto el fuego
debía entrar en rigores de martes pero
los combates continúan la República
democrática del Congo sufre la mayor
crisis de desplazamientos internos de
África con 5,8 millones de desplazados
principalmente en el este del país